it's great to welcome back to the
program rachel bittikoffer who's an
election forecaster
and analyst host of the podcast the
election whisperer
founder of strike pack and i think
rachel someone who is increasingly
concerned about what 2022 is looking
like for democrats am i right
yeah i mean you know if you're a trained
political scientist like i am
and your area of expertise happens to be
campaigns and elections voter behavior
there is no there's few uh trends in
that kind of research
that is as um adamant as robust as
continuous
as the midterm effect so you know even
before i mean
literally as a bite was walking across
the stage and
getting inaugurated the fundamentals of
this cycle
are against the democrats so you know
given what happened in 2020 not only
where they structurally had this huge
fundamentals advantage
but then the events of 2020 could not
have set up
a challenger uh trying to oust an
incumbent
better than joe biden in that fight
right seeing seeing the democrats
unable to capitalize on that down ballot
and not just because it's something that
happens right like it's something you
have to make the conditions for and they
did not
do that right uh we have a lot of
problems in our in the way our system uh
infrastructure for electioneering is uh
all the way from organizational to
tactics to strategy
that make it distinct from the
republican universe and so those two
things combined
should have everybody concerned so let's
start with like the top
level and then work to the specifics of
this next election
there's this general idea that you have
the control of the white house switch in
one election
and then in that next midterm the party
that
takes control of the house uh i'm sorry
that takes control of the white house
doesn't do well in the house often
losing now it doesn't always happen but
it it happens frequently what is there
on top of that structural thing that may
be specific
to the current slate of democrats and
republicans that concerns you for 22.
yeah i mean here let me just say in
terms of in terms of what you just said
about you know it doesn't always happen
but it happens frequently let me be very
very clear
the last 40 midterm cycles in 38 of them
right the party suffered midterm loss
in the hyper polarized polarized era
which is a
you know if you think about soil periods
or anthropology or something like that
we're living in a very distinct behavior
pattern time period of hyper
partisanship and polarization
in that era we have seen these large
midterm effects not that we've never
seen large ones in history
but we're seeing them kind of become the
staple and of course that is because we
have this
very very distinct um you know two-party
coalition
set up right now you know we didn't
always have these two parties
took a long time for them to
institutionalize and now they have these
very institutionalized
voting mates that are ideologically
homogeneous
that are you know at least especially in
the republican format
very um demographically homogeneous and
therefore you don't have like a midterm
swing because people are like
you know i tried a i've tried coke and
i'm like i mean don't try pepsi right
that's not so much of what's happening
there is always some voters moving
choice
um you know who are going from a coke to
pepsi
but what's really powering these large
midterms is that the demographic
composition of the electorate is
is switching a lot of that switch by the
way david
isn't coming from the right okay it
comes from us
participating and then pulling back
right um
and you know that's that's what i'm
trying to head off yeah let's talk about
that a little bit
i a couple weeks ago i said you know um
we had a situation like you like you're
pointing out
2020 was just ripe for joe biden
to to oust an incumbent everything went
wrong under trump and then on top of
that
you had this disastrous pandemic
response and still
while the popular vote margin was big um
it came down to relatively
free hundred thousand votes in a few
states the same way that it did in 2016
2016 could have gone hillary 2020 could
have gone trump right
i imagine that with a democrat
in the white house maybe now this is
more a 24 conversation than 22
i don't think that democrats will be as
motivated
to reelect joe biden or if it's kamala
harris and biden goes one term
and so i worry that republicans will be
reinvigorated by saying let's get trump
back in
and that's a real concern to me is that
concern warranted in your mind
that should make you guys all stay up at
night like it does me i mean here i am
days away out from uh
appendectomy and i'm doing the show
today because it's so
urgent that i i tell as many people as
possible and turn
as many people as possible onto it the
solution
yeah it's not like okay we have this
problem and
you're getting a lot of oxygen about
that in the media but
the solution is is as equally i mean
it's more important right
and the solution of course if we can
implement it here isn't so much
it isn't just about having the policy
power um
it is about staving off potentially
democratic collapse so
you know it's just so critical that
people understand
on that other side they think they're
the good guys yeah okay
they think we're the bad guys because
they're fed all of this
um hyper partisan you know red meat it's
constant crisis and threat right
and so what the things that they're
doing over there to dismantle democracy
they would tell you are in defense of it
and they believe that and we all know
objectively
that that's not true we and if we get
confused we can look at international
audiences to find out are we doing
groupthink or are we actually right
you know and and it's and it's
absolutely the case that they
they are going to be on fire to put
donald trump back in that white house
they are going to be on fire to flip
congress as
we were when we felt the threat of their
in-party power
right and um you know the democrats hope
is that oh if biden's relatively
personally popular
if we do a couple of these big packages
things will just be fine and that's you
know that was not an unreasonable hope
in 1990
or maybe even in the early 2000s but
yeah not now
because we have a distinct behavior in
the electorate
as you just pointed out as show as
donald trump's term
in office
was you know everything on hyper um
drive but also
different too because it wasn't abstract
stuff that we care about
it was pandemic is coming to kill you
your family take all your stuff
you know kill your um your personal
wealth everything right
and if you still end up with the same
contest i told you you would end up with
yeah 16 months before the election
almost did a letter i said this is
exactly how 2020 will play out
that means something's really wrong with
your political system because
when a giant stimulus comes in like that
there should be reaction right like the
thing that we should have seen
in a healthy if if politics didn't need
to change
from the 80s and the 90s then we
wouldn't have seen
a um you know repeat of 2016
and not in 1980 reagan carter
shellacking
right now along those lines i mean when
you talk about
policy and all these different things
the republican party is not really a
party of policy anymore it's communism
and socialism are going to take over
mitch mcconnell is great because he
stops democrats from doing things uh
critical race theory et cetera so how do
you run against that how do you
if you're how do what do democrats need
to do right that's the frustrating part
is
it's really easy to run against that but
not if you're
tinkering in the in the league and the
limbs of the tree okay
like our their system is built like that
like they've built
and michael steele is like you know me
and him and i are like tandem
um he was on tv last night on on brian
williams's show
trying to explain to people look this is
a like we go in there and we
we just decimate your brand like we the
reason they don't need policy
or uh achievements and i tweeted about
this last night
is that it's not to to the electorate
that sees their it's not even about
here's a or b
it's about b sucks so much that it is
going to come
and it's going to drink the the blood of
your children right i mean
that's the [ __ ] they're getting over
there right so like what strike pack is
is i mean it's many things it's a
strategic revolution it's a tactical
deployment
revolution but it's also i mean most
critically
it's a messaging revolution because it
takes
the conver like the the whole thing away
from this oh should we mobilize the base
or persuade independence
because that's a that's a it doesn't
matter what the answer is a or b
because that's not the world we live in
right now and it and it
readjustes the whole thing from the root
up to a branding
war right and in when you're in that
posture
you want to be putting them on defense
and the way to do that
isn't to defend yourself against crt and
p and defend the police and all this
[ __ ]
it doesn't matter if we could disappear
everybody that ever held that position
they would still brand every candidate
from the moderate moderate
all the way down as a defund the police
socialist that's what they'll do to
valdez we already know what they're
gonna do
right so like you can't escape that
label what you
can do is go on offense with them and
make them
own and and the nice thing is you don't
have to distort
like no democrat wants to defund the
police but now the whole party's
ascribed to this position
yeah on the republican side the things
that we're attacking them for
things they're doing they're the real
things that everybody supports that are
you know the parties congressional
leadership are doing
and you know you don't even have to get
hyperbolic even though it sounds
hyperbolic it's just the facts right
and so you make it so that the
electorate has to choose
in south florida okay socialism
right oh boy don't give me a 300 child
care tax credit um or military coup
right you pick south florida because i
can tell you this
down in south florida those populations
are afraid of socialism yeah
south america but you know what else
they're afraid of right-wing military
coups
because you look at south american
history and what has destabilized
stock stabilized south america just as
much
is like the republican party has cooking
right now in the lab
yeah i mean i think the complexity in
south florida i was just down there
is cuban americans don't care about
you know right-wing military involvement
they like it and they wanted to go into
cuba
other being from argentina myself and
having a sense of the different the
different groups there that's complex
let me ask you this intuitively it seems
to me
that a lot of trump's 24 potential is
based on whether he can successfully
play king maker in 22
whether marjorie taylor greene gets
reelected whether lauren bobert gets
re-elected etcetera is that an
accurate assessment or does that not
really matter no i mean partially david
because marjorie taylor greene and
bobart
are i mean that's the thing is like it's
you know it's so hard to like have this
like encyclopedic knowledge of the
apparatus of how elections
actually work and all that matters in a
race is you know what percent of
republican voters and their left
and their indies and demeanors are going
to be voting in that electorate versus
the other side so like you look at a
district like beau bart's or
especially greens they're not ever
getting tossed out of that seat right
uh they're drawn those districts are not
drawn in a competitive way
even from even from a republican
challenge you think that they're good
for as long as they want those seats
oh yeah they're never going to beat back
i mean you are going to go
char no it i i mean even after the
holocaust
i mean the horrible offensive stuff with
the jewish
the vaccine patches yeah i'm telling you
mor merger taylor green
it's like trying to go primary aoc on
our side and i know guys like as soon as
i say oh they're not the same
and they're not and they're nothing
alike okay yeah but the one way that
they are in like
is that they serve in districts that are
not drawn to be competitive between the
parties
okay yeah and so like they have these
distinctly ideological electorates that
they satisfy
um and you know so so the question is
this the you know the
the answer to your question is this like
okay you're not gonna be those two
and so you don't want to turn them into
symbolic um
you know um you know measurements uh but
it is true that if we can hold and we
beat back the midterm fundamentals here
and we keep donald trump from being even
in contention to become speaker of the
house
because that's the plan guys yeah the
speaker of the house doesn't come
have to come it's never been true that
they've been so rude to their own
membership that they would go recruit an
outsider
yeah yeah yeah but the rules are there
and if mccarthy thinks for one second
one second that donald trump isn't he
doesn't have enough his eye
on that speakership especially since
he's banished out in in basically that
superman world where they put the
villains out in space and they're
rotating out in that space that's where
trump is
his only point to come back into the
public debate every day
and and in a way that they have to cover
him
they don't have a choice is that
speakership okay because
otherwise he's going to stay over at
least to some degree the media is aware
of how
like they they're culpable in his rise
and his
tenure right so like they're not going
to just open the door to him
but if he breaks it down right so you
really
everything i mean they have the physical
power the
like the legal power to not certify
elections if they take control in 2022
right um i mean i don't know anybody
watching this party
could come to the any other conclusion
and then their intel goal is to fight 24
do their best to win it and then if they
don't win it win it anyway
as we've seen them uh uh claim from 2
a.m
on you know november of 2020 that also
is
it's crazy to call it a strategy but
it's a tactic at least i guess i guess
we could say
no it's not crazy to call it a strategy
okay because this is something
that got articulated as did the
election narrative that trump the media
oh trump speak like
it was the whole republican party's big
lie and they began to seed
its antecedents months before november
of 2020 and they put all of this leg
work in place that
if so that they could get in tight
margins in pennsylvania wisconsin
michigan
right preventing those ballots from
arriving and getting counted until
election night ballots came
which were anticipated to
disproportionately break for trump
so that they were creating strategically
a situation on election night
where trump would be ahead in the vote
count the other ballots have been
blocked at least from that initial night
of coverage
right and then they could contest in
court now it ended up
a wrinkle in that plan because the
margins were large
just large enough in wisconsin and large
enough in pa in wisconsin and
michigan to to make that really hard and
still
what did they do they went for it right
never make any single mistake
as hotness as they are over there the
thing that they are looping us on
is strategic planning and implementation
of those plans
they're they always where i call us
walking dead zombies we're
kind of stumbling along until the next
human sets off human activity and then
we're like oh we should go deal with
that right
they're over there like velociraptors
yeah
and they're executing it on and now we
can't afford to be
we can't afford to be aimless and so
really that strategic
um overhaul i mean we're better on
issues we're better on policy and all
the wonky
but guys like the environment that we're
in what the one thing we're not better
on
is strategy and war making and we damn
well better fix it quick
yeah a point i made earlier on on
today's podcast rachel bittikoffer
election forecaster
analyst host of the election whisperer
podcast
and also the founder of strike pack
rachel always a pleasure speaking with
you
yeah and i urge everybody go to strike
pac's website
see what these messaging that's brand
offensive branding messaging looks like
and if you can support us